now the eyes of the world are on ottawa
tonight as freedom convoy protesters
prepare for major police action in the
coming hours so you've got tow trucks
they're already on standby and earlier
today police began a mass ticketing
campaign warning protesters you must
leave the area now anyone blocking the
streets are committing a criminal
offense and you may be arrested
police liaisons even told protesters
they would be pushed out by tomorrow
that meanwhile trudeau's authoritarian
tactics have sparked a massive backlash
abroad and at home in fact today trudeau
was taken to task on the flora
parliament
where he let his true colors fly
if canadians are to trust their
government their government needs to
trust canadians those are the words of
the prime minister in 2015.
these people very often misogynistic
racist women haters science deniers the
fringe same prime minister six years
later as he fans the flames of an
unjustified national emergency
conservative party members can stand
with people who wave swastikas they can
stand with people who wave the
confederate flag we will choose to stand
with canadians who deserve to be able to
get to their jobs to be able to get
their lives back
now the courageous member of parliament
you just saw melissa lantzman joins me
now
mp landsman um thank you for joining us
tonight
now thanks for having me tell us tell us
what was going through your mind when
you heard
his reference to swastikas
look this is not a surprise to me uh you
just said it this is his true colors i
sit there and watch him dr divide
and wedge and stigmatize uh canadians
every single day and today the rest of
canada saw a g7 prime minister go after
a jewish member of parliament and then
walk away and not apologize
do you think there is an anti-semitic
element to this or was it just a slip a
verbal slip
well look i think that words matter and
if you looked at my inbox in my office
and you saw what my what my staff was uh
looking at when you accuse somebody of
standing with a swastika you get you get
an influx of people calling you a nazi
and that's not okay and he is driving
that he's been driving division in this
country uh throughout this uh uh
throughout the um uh what since the
protests started since before the
protest started for his political uh uh
gain and i think his leadership is in
trouble the country's in trouble and
he's lost control of the situation now i
would like to play now what happened
when you did demand the apology from
trudeau watch
i think he owes me an apology i'd like
an apology and i think he owes an
apology to all members of this house
[Applause]
now mp lantzman he actually left
after insulting you like that uh
that was his response kind of hit run
and hide is kind of his uh trademark at
this point your reaction
yeah look he's he's lost control and
i'll i'll just give your uh you know
your viewers i can't call that out
there's rules that say that i can't call
that out okay uh but he is he is not
like he was not there he he has not
apologized uh and i expect an apology i
gotta tell you canada is the best
country in the world my parents chose it
i'm a child of a grandchild of holocaust
survivors
and to watch what is happening and what
the prime minister is driving in this
country is frankly egregious how much
hate has been directed at you
and others who just believe in free
expression and the right to protest even
take away
concerns about mandates and the truckers
and cross border traffic set that aside
how much hate have you seen out there
just directed at you look i think the
division the division in this country is
growing and it's it's being it's growing
because of the prime minister's rhetoric
on this we've got an earl urban rural
divide we've got a an east-west uh
divide and that's being wedged uh uh by
the prime minister i'm the party's
transport uh critic so we've been
calling uh to an end to these mandates
uh particularly the cross-border
trucking mandate uh since earlier this
year we are one of you know we're one of
the highest we've got one of the highest
vaccination rates and we also have one
of the we we are the country with the
highest most draconian restrictions so
if he wants to end this today uh he
could have done that 19 days ago before
uh putting forward a national emergency
that is not justified uh he could have
gone out and uh and talked to people
rather than calling them racist and
misogynist and we could have put an end
to this he can drop the mandates and he
can drop the restrictions today
and i think that we will have a much
more cohesive country
mp lansman thank you very much for
joining us tonight and being a leader in
your country at this point hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else